depuis sa nomination hier les messages
de félicitations se multiplient en
tunisie comme à l'international najlae
bouden est donc la première femme
tunisienne a accédé au poste de chef du
gouvernement
une première aussi dans le monde arabe
une avancée majeure et une victoire dans
la lutte des droits des femmes est pour
ces magistrates politiques ou militantes
que notre correspondant à tunis ben
hassen chébili a rencontré
universitaire inconnu du grand public et
ancien chargé de mission auprès du
cabinet du ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur
najah bouden a été désigné mercredi par
le chef de l'état qu'à israël pour
diriger le nouveau gouvernement tunisien
une désignation dont la portée
symbolique et salué par de nombreuses
associations de femmes tunisiennes je
vous propose de les écouter
c'était une demande que nous avions déjà
formulée au chef de l'état à savoir des
femmes à des postes à haute
responsabilité que ce soit à la tête du
gouvernement ou au sein du gouvernement
nous souhaitions un gouvernement
paritaire donc c'est une chose positive
néanmoins nous ne pouvons pas donner
comme ça un chèque en blanc il faut un
programme clair et une vision commune
avec la présidence du gouvernement pour
que nous puissions nous aussi présenter
notre programme et la perception que
nous souhaitons de la société nous
voulons poursuivre dans la voie de la
démocratie tout en préservant nos acquis
notamment en matière de droits et
libertés individuelles et la chine
s'alourdit nous avons accueilli avec
jours à la nomination d'une femme au
poste de chef du gouvernement
nous avions déjà demandé une meilleure
représentativité des femmes à des postes
de décision et nous continuerons de le
réclamer
la femme tunisienne que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et plus que qualifiées et
compétentes
elle a toujours été une plus value sur
tous les plans et dans tous les domaines
d'ozil machette aujourd'hui hélas plus
que le droit d'occuper des postes de
décision
moi en tout cas en tant que femme
politique j'ai accueilli la nouvelle
avec beaucoup de joie comme femme et
comme politicienne avec beaucoup de jeu
reste un peu vigilante et sceptique
parce que
c'est un poste très difficile où il faut
beaucoup d'abnégation il faut une sorte
de devoir d'ingratitude
pour mener à bien cette tâche surtout
dans la tunisie d'aujourd'hui où il y a
beaucoup de difficultés notamment
économiques et sociales ou les réformes
politiques certes sont très importantes
mais moi je les vois dans la phase
actuelle un peu secondaire par rapport
aux problèmes économiques et à la crise
sociale nous on avance en tout cas je
trouve que la tunisie a toujours était
progressiste depuis l'indépendance et
qu'en matière de droits des femmes et
même avant l'indépendance et qu'en
matière de droits des femmes on ne fait
que avancer même s'il ya eu des crises
ou ca qui était vraiment très menacé une
avancée pour les droits de la femme une
formule qui revient très souvent depuis
la nomination de najlae bouden chargé
par le président de la république de
former un gouvernement dans les plus
brefs délais impossible toutefois de
savoir pour l'heure quelles seront les
priorités de la nouvelle chef du
gouvernement est nickel pouvoir lui
seront ont conféré par le chef de l'état
en attendant cailly sayed continue de
gouverner seul par décrets sans
parlement ni dialogue avec la classe
politique tunisienne aujourd'hui
toutefois la question est de savoir dans
quelle mesure la nomination de najlae
bouden équilibrera de quelque façon que
ce soit le contrôle total de l'homme
fort de la tunisie sur tous les aspects
du système politique et juridique
tunisien